ladies and gentlemen it is my great
honor and privilege on behalf of all the
scholars and staff trustees and
supporters of the American Enterprise
Institute to introduce to you my friend
the Vice President of the United States
Mike Pence
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so very much thank you for
this wonderful opportunity and I want to
thank Arthur Brooks for that mercifully
short introduction he said 20 seconds I
think it was actually shorter but I I
appreciate him so much his friendship so
to to Arthur to the Board of Trustees
and to the esteemed scholars that are
gathered here today to all the
distinguished guests as it is an honor
to be here at the new headquarters of
the American Enterprise Institute you
know I don't know where he slipped off
to I know he was headed up there he is
right there I have to tell you there's
an old proverb says there's a friend
that sticks closer than a brother and
during my days in the Congress when we
first became acquainted during my years
as governor of Indiana with periodic
phone calls I just I just want to say I
hold Arthur Brooks in the highest
professional and more importantly
personal regard he's a friend he is a
mentor and he is a great great friend of
freedom Arthur thank you so much
and I want to thank all to all the
patrons of American Enterprise Institute
for your support you are a distinguished
group of men and women and and we're
grateful for the generosity that has
made the extraordinary work now 3/4 of a
century happen in the halls of this
place
I hold you all in high regard but but I
would confess today maybe none more so
than someone who I've also had the
privilege to know for many years he's
been a patron of American Enterprise
Institute he has been a champion for
educational choice he has been a
champion for our most cherished ally
Israel and the contributions that Roger
her talk has made to the life of this
nation and to freedom will benefit this
country for generations to come
did you all join me in thanking Robert
Hedgehog for his many contributions to
the life of this nation
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for that thank you for such a
warm welcome and I bring greetings from
friend of mine who is a leader who's
fighting every day to unleash the
boundless potential of this free society
the 45th President of the United States
of America President Donald Trump wanted
me to say hello to everyone at the
American Enterprise me president sent me
here today to say thank you say thank
you for your strong support of our
agenda of less regulation lower taxes
more prosperity and and more freedom but
before I get started let me also just
take a moment to thank the American
Enterprise Institute for the unique role
that this institution plays in American
civic and public life it's amazing to
think that when AEI came to Washington
75 years ago this robust marketplace of
ideas that exists today in a thriving
network of think-tank simply did not
exist instead policy thinking in our
nation's capital was too often dominated
and by a stale intellectual consensus a
governing elite in Washington DC that
was too often too resistant to fresh
ideas and too friendly to centralized
government and bureaucratic management
the American Enterprise Institute from
its inception here in Washington DC
challenged the status quo to this day
you stand without apology for those
great American ideals of human dignity
the expansion of human freedom the
pursuit of peace through American
strength through this work AEI is
inspired and informed generations of
conservatives to join the fight for free
enterprise and constitutional democracy
in America I've seen firsthand the
scholarship and the generosity of the
men and women gathered here today I've
seen how it's impacted the work of AEI
has literally impacted not only our
nation's capital but capitals of states
all across the country I would submit to
you that the work you do here at AEI is
crucial to America's future so give
yourselves a round of applause for all
the great great
work that you've done for so many years
I'm here today to assure you that
President Trump and I share your
commitment we share your commitment of
those high American ideals and we share
your commitment to a boundless American
future as you all know well we had our
work cut out for us when we took office
on January the 20th for far too long
that the American people were enduring
an ever-growing federal government that
seemed intent on directing virtually
every facet of American life while too
often failing to fulfill its most
essential obligations to the American
people suffocated by excessive
regulation and a punitive tax system
American companies and industries too
often moved offshore taking jobs and
opportunities and futures with them
wages stagnated now more than a decade
and a half our economy stalled the most
powerful economy on the face of the
earth grew by less than two percent over
the eight years that preceded our new
administration in the midst of all of
that disappointment the American people
struggled they struggle to understand
why America seemed unable to get its
footing after the Great Recession in
2008 and before in far too many
communities across the country from
rural America to inner cities economic
mobility the dignity of work came to be
seen as a privilege of a few rather than
the birthright of every American which
AEI knows it to be but in the first nine
months of our administration President
Trump I'm pleased to report has taken
decisive action to restore freedom
opportunity and prosperity for every
American and it's already making a
difference to defend the principles of
limited government the president's been
busy appointing strict constructionists
to our federal courts at every level
including the newest Justice of the
Supreme Court of the United States
justice Neel Gorsuch
[Applause]
to revive America's economy our
administration has been rolling back
regulations that stifle American
businesses and have eroded opportunities
for working families for far too long
before this administration I only one
President had ever signed one piece of
legislation passed under the
Congressional review act I was actually
there for it I was a freshman member of
Congress in 2001 some of you may
remember the ergonomics regulations that
emerged out of the Clinton
administration in its waning days it
looked to cost American businesses
hundreds of millions of dollars and with
one fell swoop the Congress where I just
come to work took took the effort to
reverse that through the Congressional
review act it never been used again
until President Trump took office and
working with the Republican majorities
in the House and Senate I'm pleased to
report president Trump has already
signed 14 different bills under the
Congressional review act rolling back
more than 18 billion dollars in
regulatory costs on American businesses
in America in fact this year alone
federal agencies have gone on to cancel
or delay 860 planned regulations
President Trump also as we announced
recently has charged every cabinet
agency with achieving a net reduction in
federal regulatory costs and burdens by
the end of 2018 it'll be the first time
in American history that the Code of
Federal Regulations got smaller at the
same time our administration has been
busy unleashing American energy one of
our first acts in office President Trump
approved the Keystone and Dakota
pipelines earlier this month we
announced we're going to roll back the
so-called clean power plan and President
Trump put America first when he
announced that the United States would
withdraw from the disastrous job-killing
Paris climate Accord the record is clear
this president will never punish the
enterprise and prosperity of our people
he will only promote it
and already the American economy is
responding to our actions and our agenda
optimism is sweeping all across this
country patrons of American Enterprise
Institute of come here to this first
ever Washington conference can can speak
firsthand of that optimism and
enthusiasm it's remarkable to think that
for consumers and job creators alike
manufacturers actually haven't been this
confident according to surveys in more
than two decades businesses large and
small from the outset of this year have
created more than 1 million net new jobs
and unemployment is at a 17-year low all
across America
stock market is setting is setting
records reaching 23,000 and creating
nearly 5 trillion dollars in new wealth
in less than one year and after more
than eight years of less than 2% average
growth in the second quarter of this
year the American economy grew by more
than 3% and we're just getting started
the critics said it actually couldn't be
done I remember those days on the
campaign trail our third where where
President Trump would talk about getting
the economy growing again at 3% or even
four percent and I remember reading the
critics who would say that to get the
American economy back to even 3% would
take years it took about three months
because that's the strength of our ideas
and more importantly it's the strength
and ingenuity of American free
enterprise writ large but you know as a
EEI has understood throughout your
history as we focus on prosperity and a
boundless American future we do
recognize that security is the
foundation of our prosperity and I'm
here to report that this president has
also taken decisive action to ensure the
safety and security of the American
people in the early days of this
administration President Trump has
already signed the largest increase in
defense spending in nearly 10 years and
as we speak we are working with the
Congress to pass the largest investment
in our national defense
since the days
of Ronald Reagan and I'll promise you
under President Donald Trump working
with this Congress we're going to
rebuild our military will restore the
arsenal of democracy and we will once
again give our soldiers sailors airmen
Marines and Coast Guard the resources
and the training they need to accomplish
their mission and come home safe now
while some critics engage in empty
rhetoric and launch baseless attacks
this president is achieving real results
on the international stage through
through the nude American strength our
president has put historic pressure on
the regime in Pyongyang and today
North Korea is isolated as never before
with China doing more than they have
ever done to bring pressure to bear
economic and diplomatic pressure to bear
on the regime in North Korea president
Trump has put her Iran on notice in this
month he announced that our
administration will no longer certify
the disastrous Iran nuclear deal or
tolerate Tehran support for global
terrorism in Afghanistan our president
has committed our armed forces to remain
engaged in the fight against the Taliban
and all terrorist groups in the region
until we eliminate the threat to our
homeland and our people once and for all
and as was evident in the hostage rescue
in the return of a young American family
just a few short days ago Pakistan is
responding to American leadership with
renewed cooperation in the war on terror
as a candidate our president also
pledged to crush and destroy Isis in his
words and today thanks to the courage of
our armed forces and our allies Isis is
on the run it's remarkable to think that
three years ago those barbarians
celebrated in the streets of their
self-declared capital of Raqqa they
proclaimed the start of a so-called
thousand-year Caliphate as they raised
their black flags across the region but
today as I said at the Marine Corps
barracks at 8th and I as we remembered
the 34th anniversary
the Marine Barracks bombing in Beirut
today those black flags fly in Raqqa no
more just last week American and Allied
forces liberated Raqqa and across Syria
and Iraq the Caliphate is crumbling and
you can be assured we will not rest we
will not relent until our forces hunt
down and destroy Isis at its source so
it can no longer threaten our people our
allies or our way of life the facts
speak for themselves
president Trump has restored American
strength at home and abroad and I came
here today to talk about what we believe
is the single most important thing we
can do to strengthen the American
economy before this year is out with
your support we're gonna cut taxes
across the board for working families
small businesses and family farms and
get America growing again president
Trump and I are working closely with
members of Congress to pass historic tax
cut and tax reform bill this year as the
president said quote our country and our
economy cannot take off like they should
unless we transform America's outdated
complex and extremely burdensome tax
code and the people here at AEI
know of what I speak I've traveled
across America this year every place I
visit working families and job creators
have told me one thing they've told me
that the biggest obstacle to their
success is our country's broken tax code
one after another
I've sat at tables in California and in
cities large and small with small
business owners and Families one after
another spoke to me about the burden
that our tax system places on them and
the barrier that it puts in between them
and reaching and achieving their dreams
the complexity of the tax code is
something I do hear a lot about when I'm
traveling around the country today
taxpayers spend a total of 6 billion
hours every year dealing with their
taxes think about that about 94% of a
mirror
because more than 90% of small
businesses have to pay somebody to
figure out what they owe the government
all told just complying with the tax
code cost our economy 262 billion
dollars every year that's more than
eight hundred dollars for every man
woman and child in America you know it's
not just the complexity of our tax code
that hurts working families they bear
the burden of high taxes that are
imposed on businesses too nearly 30
years ago it's amazing to think America
had one of the lowest corporate tax
rates in the developed world it spurred
an era in part of soaring incomes and
jobs and growth but today we follow
behind our competitors our corporate tax
rate now is the highest in the developed
world think about that making matters
even worse our outdated system a
worldwide taxation actually penalize
a--'s businesses for being headquartered
in America by taxing every dollar that
they are in overseas our punitive tax
system is hollowed out America's
industrial heartland as well I've seen
it firsthand
being governor the state of Indiana
serving a rural district in the state of
Indiana I watched over the generations
of the way cities that were once filled
with American industry and manufacturing
and enterprise word literally hollowed
out and the tax code has been one of the
culprits that's driven that more than
anything else it's pushed our businesses
to move resources and talent overseas in
fact it's discouraged foreign companies
from creating jobs here in America as
well but those who suffer most in this
anti-competitive environment are not the
nameless faceless businesses of America
they're really every day working people
who haven't been able to find an
opportunity because of the because of
the pressures that have been placed on
our economy over the last generation
hardworking Americans who don't have the
luxury of offshoring or moving their tax
liability to another country end up
paying the price and bearing the burden
of bad policies here at home for them
when American companies and industries
move overseas they're they're left
without jobs they're left with lower
incomes with dwindling hope for the next
generation it's amazing to think here in
this in this optimistic nation how many
Ekans now will tell people in surveys
that they're not sure their children are
gonna have an opportunity to prosper
more than they did but I'm gonna tell
you what right now under president
Trump's leadership those days are over
we are going to bring real change to the
tax code and we're going to unleash the
boundless potential of the American
economy for every American to put more
money in working Americans pockets to
put our job creators back on the path to
success President Trump is committed to
sign the largest tax cut in American
history and we're gonna do it this year
I know you've already heard from Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell at this
world forum and I'm told Speaker Paul
Ryan will be here a little bit later
today and let me let me tell you how
grateful the president I are to both of
these congressional leaders for the
critical role that they've played in the
progress that we have made in so many
areas so far this year and for the vital
role that they're playing in moving this
historic tax cut plan before the
Congress as the president said we're
calling our plan the American model
which I thought would play pretty well
at the American Enterprise Institute
it's pro-growth pro-jobs pro worker and
pro-family as the president likes to say
and and basically it's four core
principles at all I'll describe to you
before I head on my way number one we're
gonna give working families a historic
tax cut under our plan will double the
standard deduction so that working
families pay no federal taxes on their
first $24,000 in income for the typical
family of four that means a tax cut of
$1,000 just to get stuff president Trump
also knows that a strong economy depends
on strong families so to provide
additional relief to America's working
families our tax cut plan will
substantially increase the child tax
credit it'll and the alternative minimum
tax and we will eliminate death taxes
once and for all
death should no longer be a taxable
event
number two we're going to restore
simplicity and fairness to our tax code
we'll cut seven brackets down to three
we'll make sure that more than 90% of
Americans can actually file their taxes
by themselves on a single sheet of paper
it's something we've talked about for a
long time I remember when I first ran
for Congress Arthur in 1988 I had a dark
hair and and was thinner now that I
think of it the truth is we were talking
about the postcard tax return but it's
literally within our grasp now and so as
we develop this consensus plan among
leaders in the House and Senate to
simplify our tax code for every American
as the president has pledged we're gonna
end the special deals for special
interests will eliminate the handouts
the carve-outs the loopholes that just
benefit the wealthy and well-connected
at the expense of working families
number three this businessman turned
president is going to cut taxes on
American businesses so that American
businesses can compete with businesses
anywhere in the world once again
[Applause]
President Trump really sees it as a
competitiveness issue and it truly is
we're gonna make American businesses
competitive again by making the United
States the best place in the world to
invest to innovate to create jobs our
plan will cut one of the highest
business tax rates on the planet from
35% to 20%
it'll end the outdated policy of
worldwide taxation and enact a
territorial system in its place and most
importantly I I grew up in a gas station
business my dad was involved in him a
small business in a small town I was
actually a gas station attendant the
first job that I had had my first name
stitched into my shirt now for those of
you that don't know what a gas station
attendant was
those of you under 30 will stop after
the program and describe it to you then
but everything I learned about public
service I learned out on the drive at
Ray's marathon in Columbus Indiana and I
was part of a family business and I know
that the majority of jobs that are
created in times of economic expansion
throughout our modern history have been
created in small business so under our
plan I'm so pleased to report not only
are we going to lower the corporate tax
rate on large corporations for thirty
five to twenty five percent but we're
going to lower the tax rate on
pass-through corporations to twenty five
percent to make sure that small
businesses will have the lowest
effective tax rate since 1931 to give
entrepreneurs and businesses even more
incentive to invest in America where our
plan will also allow businesses to fully
and immediately write off the cost of
equipment and other capital investments
because our businesses need to grow and
grow fast and so this is a this is a
pro-business pro-jobs tax cut plan and
lastly we're going to cut taxes on
literally trillions of dollars on
American companies have been locked
overseas so they can invest those
dollars in American workers American
jobs in America's future you know when I
was governor of state of Indiana I'm
humbled to tell you with the help of
somebody who now is here at American
Enterprise Institute Ryan Streeter we
actually cut taxes every single year
that I was governor of Indiana we worked
hard to create an environment in that
state that I always used to say about
the state of Indiana we did two things
really well we make things and we grow
things as manufacturing an agriculture
were at the very heart of Indiana's
economy and while we we cut taxes and we
G record employment before I left office
for my current job the truth is that one
of the one of the things that Indiana's
wrestled with that every other
Midwestern state frankly most states in
the country wrestled with was that that
stubborn indicator of her
it'll income we literally have seen
across the country for more than a
decade and a half we've seen we've seen
wage growth at at historically low
levels and and I must tell you that one
of the most encouraging things as we
talk about cutting taxes on businesses
and as American Enterprise Institute
continues to tell the story of the
opportunities this tax cut presents I
hope that you will redouble your efforts
and all of the the patrons of this great
organization will redouble your efforts
as you return to your homes around the
country to point out what what our own
kevin has it and a CAE is a Kevin
Hassett is found and that is that the
best way to give working Americans a
raise and the raise that they need and
deserve is to lower the tax burden on
businesses and job creators in America
it's truly extraordinary
now Kevin Hassett I think it was here
for a very long time and we appreciate
you making him available he's now the
chairman of the White House Council of
Economic Advisers recently this month
dr. Haas had published a study that I
commend to your attention that lays out
the overwhelming evidence showing that
working Americans stand to benefit the
most from corporate tax cuts it's a
story that we have to tell because I
have to tell you when I was governor the
state of Indiana as I've traveled around
the country the frustration that
Americans feel of seeming to work harder
every day but not getting yet any
farther along I think has contributed to
the acts that so many Americans feel in
this economy and so while we while we
talk about lowering taxes the president
is deeply committed to simplifying and
lowering taxes for working families I
would ask each one of you here at
American Enterprise Institute make the
case that when we lower corporate taxes
we're gonna make it possible we're gonna
make it possible for working Americans
to see their wages rise as well in fact
the Wall Street Journal pointed out this
morning many other economists like
Laurence Kotlikoff agree with dr. Hasson
that tax cuts for businesses raise wages
for workers all told we believe our tax
cut for American businesses will boost
wages for
Eric and workers and the typical
American household can expect an extra
four thousand dollars in their pockets
every year it's simple economics as the
scholars in this room can attest when
you cut taxes when you increase the
incentive to work invest save and
innovate and when more Americans are
working when more businesses are growing
hiring and building in America
productivity Rises wages rise and the
middle class thrives that's what
President Trump calls a middle class
miracle and we're grateful for your
support you know it's it's not just
academic theory one of the things I like
about AEI is it's all about taking
timeless principles and describing how
you can put them into practice the truth
is these have been put into practice
before everything I just described to
you about lowering taxes on individuals
and businesses and the impact that that
has on creating a growing American
economy has already been proven before
the old book says there's nothing new
Under the Sun now what will be has been
before well this specifically was before
John F Kennedy proved these ideas worked
Ronald Reagan proved these ideas work
and with your support President Donald
Trump's gonna prove they work again in
fact we believe our tax cut plan has a
potential to generate sustained economic
growth of more than 3% and spark that
middle class miracle I mean think about
what that might mean
with just three percent growth over the
next ten years will create more than 12
million new jobs and nearly 10 trillion
dollars in economic activity more
importantly the average income for
American families will rise by nearly
$7,000 over that period of time as the
president said last week this is a once
in a generation opportunity to
revitalize our economy revive our
industry and renew the American Dream
and truly it is but we need all your
help to get it done
and I want to thank all of you first and
foremost the scholars and the staff at
AEI for which
to educate the American people about the
need for tax cuts already the truth is
many of the best ideas that at the heart
of the president's tax cut plan can be
traced back to this very institution the
research advanced by your scholars has
been extraordinary you could give these
scholars a big round of applause but I'm
here today on behalf of the president
and our entire administration to say
whatever you've done before do more we
need you to keep spreading the word need
you to keep releasing groundbreaking
research continue to make the case that
tax cuts are the key to a more
prosperous future for every American a
boundless American future AEI is
renowned and respected for your
commitment to follow the facts wherever
they lead that's exactly why I'm asking
for your support of this tax cut plan
your renewed energies we do expect the
house representatives this week to vote
on the budget that was passed by the
Senate just last week that will clear
the way for the kind of procedural votes
that will allow us to move immediately
into the topic of tax cuts and tax
reform and the time between now and the
end of the year will will close quickly
and so I just encourage you I encourage
you to what you do do quickly go go tell
that story now go back upstairs in this
fancy new building use scholars and get
back to work start writing those
editorials and speaking the way that AEI
does and that your wonderful leader
Arthur Brooks does speak in the plain
language of people like me speak in the
plain language we're not well the
president the president president is
always very quick I see Steve Moore back
there president is always quick to say
he doesn't like talking about tax reform
he likes talking about tax cuts because
he wants the American people to know we
are cutting taxes for every American and
when we cut taxes on businesses it's
going to bend
working Americans so I encourage you to
go make that case and also as I close
let me just encourage all of you to just
understand there the key role that you
can play in laying a foundation in in
the public debate for making this moment
possible I truly believe that with your
help before the end of this year we'll
have on the President's desk the kind of
tax cuts tax relief and tax reform that
will benefit every American and will
open the door to a boundless American
future know as I close I would just tell
you again it's it's a great honor to be
with all of you today I've been to the
World Forum before but I don't ever
remember being invited to keynote and
I'm humbled by that I really am in my in
my new role I've been I've been
traveling around the country a lot and
my wife and I are continually amazed and
grateful for the opportunity to serve in
this capacity and we recognize this is a
it's a challenging time in the life of
our nation isn't it and it seems it
seems you turn on the television and it
seems it seems like the American people
are more divided than ever before in my
lifetime but I have to tell you I have
my doubts you know over the last month
and a half the president and I have
traveled around the country to areas of
this country that have been beset by
hurricanes and wildfires and acts of
unspeakable violence president first
lady
Karen and I traveled down to Texas and
visited this hurricane ravaged
communities we traveled to Florida and
Puerto Rico and the Virgin
president first lady went to Las Vegas
and then asked us to go to a prayer
service a few days later pray for
healing of a community literally torn
asunder by unimaginable evil and then to
see the worst-ever wildfires on unfurled
in California that's what you saw in the
news well what you get to see when
you're in a position like mine so what
sometimes doesn't come across in the
Nessa and Karen and I arrived in Texas
there was a big top tent on a church
parking lot in a community that was
literally leveled by the hurricane and
we had walked through neighborhoods and
we ended we ended the afternoon where
church ministry from Missouri had driven
down a couple tractor trailers full of
food and water to support the official
efforts that were underway
so we were walking through the big top
tent and I could see there was a small
number of people in blue shirts and a
large number of people in red shirts if
I just asked somebody what the
difference was with the shirts and they
said well the blue shirts are the people
that are from Missouri are from out of
town and I said where the red shirts
from they said here now I mean to tell
you there wasn't a there wasn't a home
in that community that wasn't flooded
and many of the homes were either
completely or partially destroyed by
this hurricane and yet there they were
standing behind tables packing lunches
for neighbors and friends every one of
them I asked I'd say how's your house
homeboys hit pretty hard it's gonna be a
while putting it back together and I'd
say to them what are you doing here and
they'd say well there's other people got
it worse than us
same thing I saw in Florida same thing
the president and I saw in Puerto Rico
the people whose lives were decimated
we're still there for each other we
visited Las Vegas there were no
Republicans there were no Democrats that
were just Americans hugging each other
holding each other praying with each
other I just I would tell all of you we
have important work to do in the days
ahead
important work to open up opportunities
of Prosperity for the American people
important work to have America standing
once again as the leader of the free
world and leading on behalf of freedom
defense of our freedom and our allies
but I just want you to I want you to go
forward with confidence and faith
because I can tell you there will always
be more that unites us in these United
States of America than will ever divide
us and so let's get to work and let's
have confidence in faith faith in the
boundless capacity of the American
people to revive this economy and create
opportunities for their families for
their communities of their state and
their nation faith in the leaders who
represent our country on Capitol Hill
and the president who leads us from the
Oval Office
faith in the entrepreneurial genius of
this country and let's also have that
other kind of faith if you're ever mind
from time to time to bow the head and
bend the need be a good time to do it to
pray for America pray for a strong and
unified America to pray for an America
with boundless opportunities for every
American regardless of race or creed or
color or division and I know that if
we'll all do that if each one of us will
leave here and do our part we will make
America prosperous again we will make
America safe again and to borrow a
phrase we will make America great again
thank you all very much and god bless
you and God bless the American
Enterprise Institute in the United
States
[Applause]
[Music]